richard schofield et président et chef
de la direction du groupe st-hubert
bonsoir monsieur schofield
bonsoir monsieur fillion quel est
l'impact du conflit de lusine de
saint-anselme d'exceldor pour le groupe
st-hubert
mais les packs ce n'est pas que direct
on manque de produits on manque de
poulet ex adore fournissez 40% en
hauteur poulet frais ont réussi en a
trouvé un peu plus chez olymel et accède
à continuer à nous fournir un quantité
minimale mais on n'y manque un tout les
jo 20 à 25 % de l'approvisionnement
travail notre réseau donc qu'il vous
manque en ce moment à peu près le quart
des poulets que vous avez généralement à
offrir à votre clientèle
effectivement est ce que ça veut dire ça
que vous devez réduire les heures de
travail réduire l'offre de services 9 de
produire votre clientèle à date depuis
trois semaines comment on gère on a
repris la gestion des commandes de
poulet pour l'ensemble de nos
restaurants on équipe al interne qui a
tous les jours qui accule des besoins
les commandes on regarde chaque matin
vers 11 heures on a aperçu de caisse qui
disponible donc une journée exemple on a
comme en 2015 puis on va savoir qui à
seulement 800 caisses disponibles on
voir distribuer la poule est disponible
dans leur pratique pour les deux emails
qu'on lisse à des restaurants desservies
par accident donc on gère pour garder le
service à tous nos restaurants tous deux
inscrit un ouvert
ceci dit oui arrive à des moments d une
journée qu'on peut manquer de poulets
rôtis on limite des commandes écho aux
commandes de gros kit est axée sur le
poulet avant on les refuse
on essaye de diriger les clients vers
d'autres produits on a arrêté les
promotions sur le poulet rôti on
maximise le balance de manu mais ce
n'est pas sa chaîne de poulet rôti on
est connue président et donc oui ça nous
cause des enjeux
on peut pas remplacer facilement ce
produit là quand le coeur de votre
produit s'il poulet est ce que vous êtes
déjà capable de calculer ou de chiffrer
les pertes pour saint-hubert dont on
n'est pas rendu là il ya un coût à tout
ça évidemment je sa gestion mais aussi
dans nos restaurants
déjà qu'à pénurie de main d'oeuvre c'est
pas facile des fois il faut qu'on
accepte un poulet qui vient dans un état
qui est pas prêt pour la cuisson donc on
doit le travail et à l'internât donc un
coût indirect à sion on est bon on n'est
pas rendus à calculer le coût pour le
moment c'est d'avoir des produits de
qualité capable de desservir de classe
parce que le poulet il est transformé
il y a battu mais il est aussi attaché à
l'abattoir n'est ce pas avant d'arriver
chez vous
effectivement et donc c'est ça en ce
moment vous recevez du poulet qui n'est
pas attaché sait comment ça se passe en
ce moment on reçoit de toute forme de
poudre seule chose qu'on fait pas
compris mais c'est la qualité du poulet
mais s'ils arrivent pas attaché on
commence à le recevoir nos restaurants
on a fait des formations à nos
cuisiniers comment la faire un long
terme mais c'est un processus très
difficile
généralement c'est fait par des machines
et équipements pour le faire au
nivellement oldies à pau donc on doit le
faire manuellement mais pour le moment
on comprend les solutions qui sont
disponibles on fait tout pour pas
manquer de produits mais ça c'est d'un
fardeau un incroyable pour les employés
nous restera avez vous d'autres sources
d'approvisionnement potentiel bien
honnêtement on a fait le tour de tous
canada on a regardé mais police mais
poggi d'avaler toutes les producteurs
possible les poulets attaché il y en a
au disponible pour nous on y mêle russie
à fournir un petit quartier
supplémentaire pour nous a aidés à et
avec des changements qu'on a fait dans
nos offres nos promotions qui des fois
accepté de manquer de poulet ont réussi
à s'en sortir
encore là on prévoit plusieurs semaines
devant nous donc ça devient de plus en
plus de cela j'ai que doit faire le
gouvernement
selon vous certaines y ait toujours la
question est ce que ces services est un
service essentiel durant la pandémie
tout qu'est ce que t'es usine tout testé
nourriture de l'été
bon qu'est ce que je comprends l'état
actuel on peut pas mettre une loi
spéciale où il semble peu probable
je trouve que lov d'arbitrage est une
solution très viable j'étais très
heureux d'entendre qu'axa d'arrêter près
d'accepter l'arbitrage
hier soir j'étais déçu de côté 1
syndicales à m'atteindre l'entente qui
voulaient pas espérons que les deux
journées de médiation vont bien vont
bien aller demain et puis vendredi
j ose espérer que si jamais il ya
toujours n'est pas sous s'avance peau le
syndicat va s'ouvrir accepté l'arbitrage
pour la semaine prochaine
alors ça veut dire quoi maintenant ça
fait trois semaines un million de
poulets et en asie si ça dure encore
quelques jours encore quelques semaines
ça veut dire quoi l'impact réel sur vos
activités au cours des prochaines
semaines et des prochains mois durant
l'été ouais ben pour nous on est déjà en
train de travailler change de promotion
en septembre octobre à 11h si le poulet
pour reprendre lundi prochain
on a quatre à six semaines avant que la
production revient normal et ça c'est
anormal dit il c'est un peu plus
difficile à cause des chaleurs à cause
des semaines les vacances de il ya
toujours un défi de plus sur la prison
poule elle était donc je prévois au
moins pour moi je pense que ça va être
six à huit semaines dès que le guen va
terminer la phase on consomme avant
assez nous sommes encore quelques
semaines avant qu'on peut se penser
avoir une résolution
donc nous aussi qu'est politiques ont
assez de trouver des solutions on trouve
des manières différentes pour gérer un
produit que hypo de la spécification
comprend d'habitude on est en mode
solution on n'a pas le choix
voilà bonne chance merci cisco firent
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez vous sur
la chaîne ici et redit